I'm now gonna do something a little bit
weird you could have done this question
without any extension to knowledge okay
we've worked this and that's sort of an
extension to way of writing but you
could actually gone straight to here you
can still generate this line by thinking
about the difference in volumes that's
fine
but watch this if I think about the
volumes right the area between say
either x equals two x equals three let's
let's put some points on here and then
generate our area okay so if I say if I
wanted to rotate this area around the
x-axis that'll be fine I don't need any
you know special knowledge to do that
but what if I want to rotate somewhere
else what if I had a different axis of
rotation that's not a coordinate axis
now this is not that hard to imagine for
example this is a curve what why does on
the nexus is two and three so what is
this value that corresponds to the x
equals two
that's a half right and I could do a
third as well what should be the Y value
of that so that's a half then up here
twice its height is one it's one how
about the line y equals one now I'm
still keeping it nice and simple I'm
still giving you something that's
parallel to a coordinate axis it's not
gonna be that crazy okay what shape will
we get if we were taken not around a
coordinate axis but around this line
again you should put in that area of
rotation to show number one which
stretch here going in and where you're
rotating around because I'm still at the
same direction here it's still this way
but I've got different locations
different axes what's this thing gonna
look like I could draw it for you right
now in fact I will shortly but I want
you to see if you can work out with that
mean give me two just yet can you do
this volume work out what kind of shape
you go I'll give you a bit of a
headstone okay so here's what I've come
up with okay now it's a little bit weird
to think in this way because we're not
used to sort of going in this opposite
direction but in principle it's not that
different from what we did before in
that the shape you're gonna get up here
the area you're gonna get up here in
fact at risk of making this diagram too
crazy the area you get on the top
I because you're rotating is going to be
a reflection of the area you have done
here do you see that so it's not that
difficult to work out what that shape is
going to be the top edge which by the
way what is the equation of the top edge
it's horizontal it's gonna be y equals
two isn't it how do we how does that how
do we give them purpose so this is in
the middle yeah so you think from the
axis rotation you come down to zero well
if you've gone down to zero you need to
go up the same distance to get to your
opposite edge right so that's what you
go at one in the same way you can see
I'm not going to draw the line across
because it's way too easy it's on my
diagram but this point here is where
I've got this edge from and again I can
work out by a reflection what that value
is what is the value it's much we wanted
to so it's one and it's one and a half
isn't it and in the same way if you
wanted to work out with values right
again thinking of the reflectional
symmetry that's here that distance there
is a third off the axis right the
coordinate axis doesn't say so this
should be a third off of that top edge
so if I went to one more number it give
me one and two thirds five thirds so
there's the picture that's why I've got
now how would you approach this as a two
unit student then the answer is with
great difficulty okay
you'd probably in order to solve this in
order haven't cheated approach to this
you have to actually shift this
somewhere else so that you're rotating
around a corner axis you have to move
this thing down
one unit and then you could say okay
well how about this and then I'd work
from there okay it's still gonna be if
you I'm going to take this new idea and
say look I don't care where it is can I
work out if I cut across perpendicular
to your rotation of that your ax the
rotation what kind of shape not going to
get and just like before can still
rotating I'm going to get and handless
so over here
will you draw for me an example of an
annulus that you could get by slicing
this thing by a bad way there's little
um there's tiny little lines you have to
put them there no of course not
but I like putting them there because
they give me visual cues for what this
shape is supposed to represent they
should make it clear up for me it's for
my head okay now we've also got this is
okay so just like before I'm going to
have the height of my oculus which I'm
still gonna say is Delta X right
if I were retaining around a vertical
axis in a VR not a delta X by a delta Y
or a delta anything just like before
remember how I said okay we're lifting
the veil on this right here's what I had
do remember I said hey you can change
what kind of a shaking gun you don't
have to do cylinders you can do an
annulus right well guess what else you
can change if you don't limit yourself
to just say Delta X good way you can
rotate around any way you'd like and
you'll just have a delta something else
okay so again I'm getting em myself but
very exciting I've got my height what
else do I need on this thing I need a
little radius and a big radius okay so
I'm going to put them
now this is a bit interesting right
where will I go from his not quite as
straightforward as before and just you
read off what the you just read the
functions now you read one on X you read
e to the X and that was it
okay this is a little bit different then
you give you a clue the big radius is
much easier to work out than the little
ways what's the big radius it's just
going on look it's one this way it's one
that way done I don't need to say
anything about that I could it doesn't
have to be constant as you saw with E to
the X and 1 or x by this case it is now
this little redness its little radius
now wearing before we read off what the
functions were right that just tells you
the height of this thing here on by the
legs worth mentioning these two radio
obviously is saying because they're
radiographer now where is one on x on
this diagram where is it and the answer
is it's that height right form the
x-axis up to here this is our definition
for y right so this is y equals 1 of X
but of course these two things together
comprise the big radius
do you agree so therefore this is the
difference between the big radius and
the height of your function so this in
fact is one take away this guy does that
make sense
that'll to be real that corresponds to
that vertical shift that I was saying
you'd have to do if you want to cheers
to a purchase point so now I'm ready now
I can make a statement like that I could
say a new color that's easy to be
because I need some light for work what
is my volume okay again lifting the veil
I need to think about the fact that
there's only bit involved and it's Delta
X being very very braided I'm adding up
now and I actually have boundaries now
that's kind of nice x equals to 2 x
equals 3 and then what I'm adding up is
what's this infinite series made up of
they're not cylinders they are and
yellow slices right so then follow you
govern any sizes
hi again just to make it easier for my
brain I'm going to put those two things
there times Delta X and then in my next
line I'm going to convert to my integral
so I've got two to three now I'm ready
to say what these things up big radius
just one
so I swear it and then I take away their
little radius which we you help me work
out is that square and have you
accounted for the limit by now if you
say I'm gonna call this thing DX rather
than Delta X so far so good
trakula with me let's do this this is
this actually has a size so let's go
I'm gonna take my PI out two to three
one takeaway what am I going to get in
these brackets the x pi/2 three kids
will cancel right that leaves us with
it's a double negative there so it's two
on X Wow this is the easiest integral in
the attention to coast you'll ever
encounter notice substitution required
integral of studio 2x of course is 2x
now because this is actually minus X to
the minus 2 right you or they give to
you rather you push the power up by one
if you should negative one maybe you
divide by that path which cancels the
negative that you already had there so
this is just one of those from 2 to 3
okay now let's just quickly evaluate
this someone's going to need to help me
with a calculator in a second I'm going
to log 3 take away too long to do a
little bit with my claws in here that's
gonna be logged I and that's gonna be
log 4 and I'm doing a subtraction right
so this is actually volumes 9 on fort
you agree I'm a third take away a half
that's gonna be minus 6
yes dude right ok can we
decimal on them can give you a common
service a 2.0 two to four to three
decimal places
okay now let's just pause for a moment
skipping we worked out the volume it
wasn't actually that hard right like
once you've got this idea it sorry this
side you're out of the way
it's like well that's just gonna give me
this particular ambulance okay now how
do you do it whether you are right or
not
unfortunately come from alpha and things
like that they're only gonna take like
algebra they're only gonna take
something like this which assumes you've
got it right in the first place
so if I know this is gonna be true then
of course I'll get that what tools do I
have at my disposal to actually compare
and check whether I like the first way
is if I've got something that you do but
clearly something is going on here in
the science that they get it for you
that's a bad sign okay now I'm going to
do something a little more well a little
more basic I'm just going to think about
comparing this this whole thing to a
volume that is much easier
draw draw this with me okay so why don't
you picture is what I want you to
imagine is let's just take something
that's quite close to this and I'm gonna
simplify dramatically so that I can work
out easily and find out whether I'm in
the ballpark or not okay
let's imagine instead of this curvy part
the curvy part is what makes it
complicated let's make everything
straight okay so the radius that's big
is still going to be one just for the
sake of simplicity let's call the little
radius let's call it half right I know
that's this value here right so when I
go across there I'm going to just
simplify this out this is super easy to
work out okay the volume is going to be
five times
this right this is the this is your idea
of sort of thing right ah squared minus
R squared times DX which is what like
why is that one where's that come from
it comes from that distance it's the
height right okay in this case a squared
is 1 this is 1/2 so that's gonna be a
corner so it can someone tell me what
3/4 of pi is okay not on me does that
match what you expected is this volume
gonna be bigger or smaller than the
actual volume I want it should be bigger
right cuz look what I've done is seen
these plastic bead carved out I just
kind of I patted them up until they were
straight right so I've added a little
bit to see exactly what I expected to it